let's apologize if my impression views
are incredible right large Bible I am
James McAvoy I'm Sarah Paulson and today
we're going to be playing first
impressions hello
I'm really bad at doing accents I'm a
comedian and I'm incredibly funny no
that's not right I've written books and
I've also directed some films yes
Richard a wide a thanks sorry Richard
oh listen I just want to talk to you
about and I laughing about and then by
the Holly Hunter Oh
so let's apologize if my impression of
you is incredible right yeah you know
sage but then that's the Overlord sex
part like no he doesn't have a sexy -
yeah you said oh I says you have a lot
of issues used to have a little addition
problems I'm still really funny Russell
Brand yes
ring a ding a dong dong there's no
passion involved there's no but I liked
it
[Laughter]
birds Big Bird I'm not a bird but I'm a
tall being in a movie with fen about fur
on me and I'm making up sound we're like
but that may not be what he does at all
I'm in a movie with lightsabers is a
joke I made up when I was a little boy
who's the biggest wanker or gadget actor
and Star Wars Han Solo who's gay the
most disgusting habit in Star Wars
Chewbacca Jabba the Jar Jar Binks no oh
genetic just the species Oh an alien
that's a part kind of what some drastic
park
a pterodactyl dinosaur to end all junket
oh yeah dude that voice I'm just a voice
of a gun oh thank you you're welcome
mmm he's got your tiny purse and I'm
very very thank you I think people are
laughing because it's really bad but I'm
I'm very old but very well no no no
could you could you actually honey
really yeah
should you hit me one more time
a draw I'd like to play till I win
you've been watching first impressions
flank misfortune lad by rocky I'm what
they call a lad
so I'm suction bad I'm the latias
you